silyl Kapoor joins us he's national
political reporter for Bloomberg News
Sal good morning as always a lot to talk
about but let's start with the mess in
Virginia with both the governor and
lieutenant governor facing bipartisan
calls for resignation how do they get
out of this mess it's a train wreck for
Virginia Democrats at this point they
are facing calls to resign the top three
Democrats in Virginia are facing
bipartisan calls to step aside and if
they do that they would be handing over
power to the Republican Speaker of the
House in a redistricting cycle where
they're redrawing the map so they're
hanging tight right now they are they've
all taken a somber reflective somewhat
apologetic tone but it's not clear any
of them are going to step aside at this
point what about on the national stage
for Democrats I mean obviously for them
in Virginia it could be somewhat of a
success succession crisis if they have
to go to a Republican next but what
about on that national stage right well
national Democrats are very cognizant
you know that they don't want to be tied
in with this stuff which is why so many
of them are calling on their colleagues
to resign just yesterday five Democrats
in the Virginia a congressional
delegation said the lieutenant governor
has to go and we can keep in mind the
Democratic Party is being held to
account increasingly by a base of
african-americans and women who have no
tolerance for racism and sexual assault
you just wrote our penned we should say
a note on the 2020 presidential
candidates are the Democrats filled is
it too far to the left and is there room
for a moderate here there may be in a
large field but Democrats have certainly
decided to throw incremental ISM in the
trashcan they're going big bold
visionary kind of returning to the roots
of FDR where they want to increase taxes
sharply on wealthy people to mitigate
income inequality and to use the funds
to expand the safety net issues like
Medicare for all and debt-free college
and even a wealth tax Senator Warren has
proposed on assets about 15 million have
you know gained a lot of traction within
the party we just saw the House
Judiciary Committee hearing with acting
attorney general Whittaker which was
quite contentious as we saw in that
piece what's your what's your takeaway
from that in terms of what the mood is
gonna be in Congress and hearings like
this going forward
he was very defiant you know he was
clearly playing to an audience of one as
many people in the Trump administration
do when they're testifying he said he
had not interfered in the Malheur
investigation the Ruscha investigation
anyway which was significant but he did
not get into
his role and controversial decisions
made at the Justice Department like the
firing of James Comey and the family
separation policy and more fireworks
probably to come whenever we see
hearings like that so he'll thank you so
much for the update thank you